تمر متوهجه وخاطفه تبهج الناس وتصيبهم
بالحيره بعض الثقافات تستبشروا برؤيه
النيازك والمذنبات واخرى تعتبرها نذيره
شؤمن يستدعي الفزع وفي امريكا يسود
الاعتقاد بان رؤيه الشهب فرصه لطرح
الاماني علها تتحقق ولا نعرف ما خطر في
بال الانسان القديم حين برق المذنب الاخضر
في سماءه قبل 50,000 عام لكن ذلك المذنب
ذاته يعود ليزين الافق هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
كره الجليد هذه تقطع اكثر من 200,000 كلم
في الساعه وستكون الاقرب الى الارض بحسب
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا في الثاني من
فبراير محلقه 100 مره ابعد من القمر
حين تمتص جزيئات الكربون ثنائي الذره اشعه
الشمس
وسيسلط علماء الفلك في الولايات المتحده
تلسكوب جيمس ويب لمراقبه المذنب الاخضر
حين يقترب من المريخ لفهم هذه النوعيه من
الاجرام السماويه على نحو افضل
يمكنك رؤيه هذا المذنب النادر بالعين
المجرده من مكان بعيد عن اضواء المدينه
انظر الى النجوم وستجد المذنب يتلالؤ بين
نجم الشمال ونجمتين في نهايه كوكبه الدب
الاكبر لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن